great too so we have a trailer for Cree
- it's a bit of a vague trailer but
there's enough to talk about here
because I felt Crete was something
really special arguably the best of the
Rocky movies it's not really rocky
moving doesn't matter it's great and
from what I can piece together it looks
like in Crete - Adonis Creed has his
life he has his happiness and Ivan Drago
son comes into the picture Ivan Drago is
Dolph Lundgren he's the one who killed
Apollo Creed and rocky for it was the
son of the father who was killed
fighting the son of the Father who
killed the father that was killed and
there's some pretty deep stuff you can
do with this movie you see rocky talking
to Adonis Creed and he's like this is
dangerous man your dad died in my arms
your dad sounded like how you sound now
don't fly so close to the Sun that's how
you get burned it's how your Icarus
wings burn off live your life if
happiness but Adonis Creed wants revenge
even as mom's like do not even say this
is about your dad it's not it's a
revenge tale if it was a Donna's Creed
fighting Ivan Drago I'd get it but it's
Adonis Creed fighting the son of Ivan
Drago Ivan Drago son didn't do anything
to Apollo Creed so it's a real sins of
the father thing the sons are fighting
the father's war so where does it stop
where does it end
is Ivan Drago son even an [ __ ] I
think that's the more interesting route
they could take is if Ivan Drago son is
a good fighter but what if he's not a
dick what if he's like I'm sorry about
father he was maybe Drago Sloan just
isn't the [ __ ] Adonis Creed thinks he
is I feel like I like that a lot more
and again it's all about execution
sometimes apples fall far from the tree
just want to see how far this one falls
it does look like Adonis Creed gets his
ass kicked is in a hospital beds always
creed to going the continuation of rocky
4 but it's the rocky 3 route where he
gets his ass beat he's kind of down on
his luck he trains gets his mojo back
and he gets back into the ring or is he
in a hospital bed because it's like yeah
that fight with that last dude at the
end of the first movie that was
something I'm theorizing way too much
for a great movie like I feel like I'm
over complicating it if we're honest
with ourselves is probably gonna be as
simple as Adonis Creed fights the son of
the man who killed his father he has to
decide what's he fighting for his father
or himself and that'll be that let's not
overcomplicate it with theories you're
like I would did that like how I filmed
an entire video edited an entire video
had the whole video dedicated to making
a point then at the end of this video
rendered that entire video useless
that's gotta be some sort of superpower
to be able to do that right what is
after this one I what scream 3 gonna be
about I swear to Christ if Creed 3 is
Adonis Creed has brain damage and then
trains a dude with
mullet and then they fight in the street
at the end but I'm out really interested
to see where they go with this one I'm
sad Ryan Coogler is not doing it gonna
be some stair downs though between
Stallone and Dolph Lundgren blunderin
can't wait for that passive-aggressive
boxing but interested to see where they
go with this one I have my thoughts I
have my theories I think I know where it
can go I think I know the route I want
it to go wherever the movie goes as long
as they execute it well that's a win I
just want a good Creed sequel it looks
like it could be that but the Creed III
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]